since we're talking about the future let
me ask you the timeline question
or even just like definitional what is
alonso
you mentioned uh some fun hello world
experiments going on right
uh and how and when will cardano get
smart contracts yeah so alonzo church is
a famous famous mathematician computer
science guy and he was a contemporary of
turing and
there was like these three different
views of computing recursive functions
from girdle and turing machines from
touring and
your church has lambda calculus and
they're all equivalent and they all give
you the ability to build a computer
so we like functional programming so we
decided
that's your favorite church to do so we
had to name something after church and
it's it's just weird that
you know we never did so we said okay
alonzo is is a good release name
basically was bringing smart contracts
to cardano it took us a long time to get
here and
we'll be there in the next 90 days you
know it's uh
we like everything we do there's a
process and so there's all the colors of
the rainbow we start with alonzo blue
and then white and purple
uh and each step you do some more things
you bring more users in
and then eventually you get to a
threshold where you say okay everything
works the way intended and you push a
button
and we initiate what's called a hard
fork combinator event and boom
the system has smart contracts you just
wake up and it's there
it's like it's in your house this is
gonna be it's like when i got my blue
check mark on twitter i woke up and i
had it
yeah it's just like christmas and you
were never the same you can never you
can't go back it's uh yeah like hard
fork it's a hard fork of charles
yeah exactly you've got blue well
actually i think you can take it away
but can they take my check mark away
but they'd be like a hard fork backwards
i guess
okay so so great so that's uh but
currently there's uh
so there's um there's a testing
procedure
going on to see what does that look like
and what will give you confidence that
things are working well yeah so first
you start with the mary era which is
where we're right now multi-asset so
you can do metadata and issue tokens on
cardano but you
you have limited programmability on
chain alonzo adds the programmability in
but we already have most of the the
foundations of the extended utxo model
and the smart contract model is just
those things aren't ready
so the first step is say fork it so all
those rules are now there
okay so that's what we did with lonzo
blue we we forked
a test net based layer and it's
successfully survived
going from mary to alonso which means
that you can move transactions from one
side to the other both systems work
and then the next step is say okay well
are the stake pool operators people run
the infrastructure able to run this test
net just like they run cardano and
that's what we're doing right now with
blue we're bringing all these spos in
and then are we able to submit and run
smart contracts on the system and they
actually
return a round trip you send something
you get something back yay okay
um so that's where we're at and then
what you do is each step
so the next is white you go from like 50
people to several hundred
and then purple's an open test net where
we want every single person the entire
ecosystem to use it it's also a devnet
so that means that people are writing
with blues playground and local
interpreters their their smart contracts
can actually start testing them now
on the public infrastructure so it's
kind of like releasing
dev kits to the xbox or something like
that you send them out to game
developers before you release the xbox
so they can test their video games in
anticipation
of the release of the system so you run
that for at least a month and
as long as it doesn't blow up in your
face and oh god what have we done
hindenburg all the humanity
uh you release it and you know you ship
it the problem is it's no longer in our
control
you know there's over 100 exchanges that
have listed cardano there's lots of
wallet infrastructure there are
thousands of different constituencies
so it's less of a technological problem
now and it's more of a coordination
problem
so you have to evolve in a very
methodical way
and each step of the way you bring new
actors in they get ready for it they
upgrade their infrastructure to it and
then like shells
eventually you get to the outer shell
which is the hard fork for the general
public
and if we've done it right like that
blue check mark they wake up and
it's exactly the same what do you just
get a little update then
update your client and they start
demanding wagyu beef
is there stuff you're worried about in
terms of like when
something's this tricky you know
goes up several orders of magnitude in
terms of scale
are there problems that you foresee is
there like um
like we said there's game theoretic
aspects all those kinds of things uh
like what worries you the most i i mean
i sleep like a baby i wake up every two
hours crying
um damn that's a good one
you're full of good lines um i mean
there's a lot it just made me realize
that expression makes no sense
i slept like a baby but go ahead yeah
exactly right
messing your whole world up right now
alex um
no i mean there's so much that keeps me
up at night you know it's like you're in
a cold sweat every day when you have an
ecosystem like this because you you you
the other thing is you're judged as much
by the applications people build on the
platform as you are
by the platform you've constructed so
you know one of the most unfair things
that happened in our industry was
blaming vitalik for the dow hack he
didn't write the code he wasn't
responsible for it a completely
independent different team
and because it blew up a lot of people
just developed this idea ethereum is not
secure the vm is fundamentally broken
and it's true there are some issues
there but
come on that's that's like saying oh
well you know photoshop didn't work [ __ ]
bill gates
yeah you know and that's the issue is
you get you get you get
as a platform developer you know enter
it coupled with the wins and losses of
your application developers so if they
go do amazing things it's like
oh yeah windows is great we love it if
they go do terrible things they're like
oh man i guess he's trying to kill all
of us
um so what we're kept up at night about
is not just what we've constructed but
also how do we curate
an ecosystem and foster the development
of an ecosystem where you have assurance
baked into the
application and that's somehow
expressible to the user so when you
download your smart contract or you
click your one click install to use your
unit swap clone or whatever the hell it
is that's deployed on cardano
you have a little green check mark or
something that indicates to you that
somebody audited the code or it followed
a specification
the lack of that is problematic because
then
first there's impersonations the whole
myetherwallet thing like your videos or
my videos are the same
every comment there's a bot that says
hey you know give me some money or
something like that
that kind of stuff happens but then just
protocol level flaws like what happened
with the dow hack
that's what really keeps me up at night
how do you resolve that problem
because i don't hire these people i
don't tell them what to do i didn't tell
them how to build things on the platform
they may have tons of experience and
knowledge they could be simon payton
jones
or they could have absolutely no
knowledge whatsoever and they read one
tutorial and they've written three lines
of code their entire life
and they've deployed something horribly
broken copy paste and suddenly it all
goes to hell
i'm judged by both that's what really
keeps me up at night and we're
as a company trying to figure out and
it's the ecosystem trying to figure out
standards like at university of wyoming
we're setting up
the smart contract engineering institute
we're negotiating with them right now
and the goal there is just to create
some you know standards for
how to certify smart contracts and so
that you can get that green check mark
and know that
it actually has some assurance level
behind it but god that's a huge
coordination problem
and it's a huge information presentation
problem and incentives problem and so
forth and
unfortunately people who value being
first to market will kind of piss in the
pool for everybody else
you